I think it represents a level of
behavior that is completely unacceptable
we have to be able to operate on the
basis of confidentiality a relationship
with the US particularly in terms of
intelligence and security is our most
important relationship globally and I
think this sort of leak is
unprofessional it's unethical and
ultimately unpatriotic and what does it
say about the state of our government
when you know the UK's ambassador in
Washington cannot send confidential
memos without them being leaked well
that's because it's not a UK or only
problem here in the US that's also has
been a problem I think it says a lot
about the ethics of of individuals in a
system that generally works very well to
have one or two people who maliciously
for political or other reasons decide
that they're not going to fulfill their
own duty of confidentiality I think is
at best very disappointing I think this
is a particularly serious case and I
hope that if we're able to find the
culprit that heads will roll it can't be
that difficult to find them very few
people would have had access to this do
you think it's the civil service or
would you say it's politicians
impossible to say at the moment from any
information that I have I think that if
you look at the number of documents
involved that the the circulation may be
relatively narrow but of course we all
face a situation in our society nowadays
where people get copied into things
without that being necessary and I think
that we all need to be very careful but
the processes that we have about copying
emails in particular
so you think memos like this about our
most important ally under the presidency
of Donald Trump get cc'd to various
different people dear well I'm not sure
exactly who will have been copied I
think it's a general problem that we
have but we have to have a situation
where our embassies around the world and
that goes for our partner nations as
well they also have to be able to get a
frank assessment from their own
diplomatic staff about what's happening
in the UK we need that to happen to be
able to have democratic systems working
properly isn't it most likely though to
be
a politician who has taken offense to
sir Kim D X basically pro-europe view it
it may have been a brick Satya I have
absolutely no idea and I think
speculation is pointless
until we carry out a proper
investigation okay
Donald Trump takes these things very
personally as you know will it
complicate what you're there to do which
is to negotiate the basis for a future
trade deal no we'll be talking across
the administration to various
individuals and the same on Capitol Hill
to talk about market access issues of
course you have to remember that in the
United States not all trade policy is
actually made by the federal government
a lot of trade policy will be done at
the state level so getting a better
understanding of what happens there is
important it's worth pointing out that
if the the states and the united states
were independent countries four of them
would be in the g20 right and I
understand that you're planning to
apologize to Ivanka Trump the
president's daughter but these were the
sort of honestly held views of the UK
ambassador what do we have to apologize
for exactly oh no I'm not apologizing to
anyone in particular but what I would I
think say is that you know it's a great
pity that we can't depend on the
integrity of our own system to be able
to ensure that those views are kept
confidential you know all my time and I
practice as a doctor you worked in an
arena where confidentiality was was was
Center in terms of of how you carried
out your work and it used to be that
that was true in politics it now seems
that some people think that their
personal views or their personal
vendettas or their personal missions
take precedence over the national
interests that can never be allowed to
happen which is why whoever is
responsible needs to have the book
through an anthem yeah I mean but you
said early be apologizing to Ivanka
Trump I don't understand quite why
surely the apology should go to Sir Kim
Dirac I didn't say I was apologizing to
anyone particular I read it in The Times
this morning
but I think it's feared that we should
be seeing to our American counterparts
that it's a pity that we've been unable
to maintain the integrity of our own
system asked for our ambassador in
Washington I think he's a fine public
servant who's done a very good job but
clearly he's been let down by the
political system itself whether by
accident or as looks more likely by
design and that sort of malevolent
behavior cannot be tolerated right I
mean the Prime Minister says she doesn't
intend to apologize to president Trump
much of what Kim Dericks said are quite
widely shared opinions that you know
people believe that it might be a
slightly dysfunctional administration to
say the least do you share those
opinions no I don't share those opinions
and in any case it's not what the
ambassador said that is the issue here
it's about the inability of the system
to be able to transmit that
confidentially to ministers ministers
require to have that absolute certainty
that the conversations that go in both
directions are genuinely confidential
without that the trust on which we base
our democratic system starts to break
down that is the real problem okay just
a couple more I mean what should happen
to whoever is found to have done this if
someone is discovered to have done this
well it depends who they are it depends
on the level of classification of
documents involved if it's an internal
disciplinary matter that has to be dealt
with with the utmost severity if it is a
criminal matter than it needs to be
dealt with by prosecution we simply
can't allow this thing to happen and if
it was a senior minister they should be
sacked immediately and possibly
prosecuted well it shouldn't matter
anyone who breaks the law whether there
are civil servant or a minister or
anyone else should be subject to the
full force of the law and that's what I
hope will happen here